si ces pays qui se sont rapprochés un dé
facto de l'otan c'est le cas de la
finlande et de la suède déjà proche de
l'alliance ces deux pays envisagent
désormais de la rejoindre sérieusement
la finlande qui partagent je vous
rappelle plus de 1300 km de frontière
avec la russie elle a une bonne longueur
d'avancé sur une suède plus prudente
tout en en tout cas renforce ces
dernières jours leurs armes et on en
parle avec notre invité car arfa bonjour
professeur agréé en études de guerre à
l'unité suédoise de la défense vous
intervenez en direct de stockholm
première question sur ce risque d'une
attaque russe on sait que le scénario
est régulièrement abordé il est pris au
sérieux chez vous aujourd'hui
oui absolument bonjour merci beaucoup de
cette invitation mais oui évidemment de
le risque d'une attaque russe est pris
très au sérieux la minute la minette a
évidemment augmenté il avait
l'environnement sécuritaire dans toute
la région a changé avec l'invasion de
l'uriné par mieux évidemment n'oublions
pas que nous n'oublions pas que la
finlande est ce que vous mentionnez
avant une frontière non négligeable avec
la russie l'île suédoise de gotland et
au milieu de la baltique donc on est
dans un contexte de proximité
géographique très importante mais de
façon peut-être encore plus importante
je dirais il ya des avertissements
fréquent de la part de la russie envers
la suède et la finlande
le dernier était ce dimanche par exemple
où la russie a averti qu'il pourrait y
avoir des conséquences militaires
importantes si la suède par exemple
décidé de devenir membre de l'otan de
manière similaire il ya deux semaines il
ya eu lors d'un entraînement de la
finlande avec la suède sur l'île de
gotland à la présence des ministres de
la défense de la finlande et de la suède
des rues un survol de la part de quatre
avions de chasse qui ont évidemment
violé l'espace aérien suédois donc on
met donc tout cela se passait un risque
vraiment sérieux qui est pris au sérieux
mais en même temps je dirais personne ne
croit vraiment à la possibilité d'une
attaque imminente mais il est désormais
très clair qu'il faudrait bien qu'il
faut bien se préparer à cette
éventualité
quoiqu'improbable donc il ya toute une
série de mesures qui sont mises en place
par exemple une expansion des budgets de
la défense des nouveaux exercices
militaires les renforts sens le renfort
de là par exemple de la conscription
militaire obligatoire qui est très forte
en finlande qui est en train d'être
enfoncée on souhaite aussi soit là la
question de l'otan sur cette simple
question de de l'automne comment réagit
l'opinion publique c'est vrai que c'est
souvent intéressant de de tâter les
réactions ici et là il semblerait que
elle est largement évolué assez vite là
aussi un
alors là on est vraiment on est en train
d'observer un changement un pivot
historique on n'a jamais vu une chose
pareille pas seulement le soutien à
faveur de la de rentrer dans l'eau tan
est très élevée on souhaite et en
finlande mais aussi le pourcentage des
indécis et à des niveaux très élevés le
soutien de l'opinion publique à jean
l'otan n'étaient pas traditionnellement
la laisser il s'agit quand même de deux
pays qui ont traditionnellement été pour
des raisons très différentes non alignés
et donc on a vraiment mais vraiment
jamais vu ça juste pour vous donner un
exemple le jour deux jours après la
l'invasion de l'ukraine le 53% des
filins des se disaient favorables en
traitant est reparti de l'otan juste il
ya deux jours il ya des on a déjà à 62%
de que c'est vraiment une un changement
historique on avait déjà mais jamais vu
avant et et il s'agit aussi des deux
pays qui ont été à un niveau de
l'opinion publique très stable sur cette
question là donc sa chute de quelque
chose de vraiment nouveau c'est le cas
aussi est ce que les partis politiques
suivent ces changements qui sont en
train de s'opérer au sein de l'opinion
publique s'est pas souvent le sait pas
toujours le cas où c'est vrai ils
suivent mais pas tout à fait donc il ne
faut pas oublier que les partis
politiques qui sont les parti lider des
collections du gouvernement actuel qu'on
souhaite mais aussi au flanc en finlande
sont traditionnellement contraire à
rejoindre l'otan dont il s'agit de deux
partis social démocratique qui pour pour
lesquels la être non alignés constitue
une dimension très forte très importante
leur identité de partie pour des raisons
assez différente donc
ce que on est en train de voir est d'un
côté il ya lille ya une différence
importante entre la finlande et la suède
la finlande est un peu en train de
d'accepter ceci donc là la première
ministre sanaa marine de deux heures en
fait après l'invasion de l'ukraine
annoncé avec le président de la
république finlande et annoncé que on
devait commencer des discussions
sérieuses sur peut-être rejoindre l'otan
la suède un petit peu différente c'est à
dire que la suède est un peu moins clair
et moins précise pas la sienne n'a pas
encore décidé de quoi vraiment quoi
faire donc le parti social démocratique
ce doit être très très divisé et il ya
beaucoup de désaccords car il ya
beaucoup qui pensent qu'il s'agit d'une
politique la politique de non alignement
de ne pas être membre de l'otan qui a
servi la suède très très bien qui est un
peu la raison de son succès aussi donc
ils sont un peu en train on souhaite
d'explorer un peu les alternatives par
exemple la clause de défense de l'union
européenne
continue et la coopération avec la
finlande parmi parmi d'autres choses
mais moi je dirais que en tout cas ce
bluff un peu que la suède était non
alignés a un peu été dévoilée c'est
clair que là la suède a en fait aligner
elle est du côté du pays et des pays
occidentaux et dont tout je pense n'est
pas vraiment un peu d'aidé semaine
prochaine je pense si dans quelques
semaines par exemple l'avancement de la
russie en ukraine s'arrête ou ralentie
au moins je pense au moins on souhaite
on va oublier ça et cela peut être ne va
pas être le cas on attend ce qui va se
passer en ukraine on vous comprend bien
ce sont des dévié réflexion finalement
qui ont connu un coup d'accélérateur
certains traits peut-on en vingt jours
seulement et tout l'enjeu c'est
évidemment de pouvoir bénéficier en cas
de besoin dans un avenir proche ou
lointain d'une protection de l'alliance
militaire ça prendrait du temps pour
autant
oui oui et non donc d'un côté bon
évidemment si les pays si la finlande et
la suède décidé de rentrer dans le temps
la clause numéro 5 entrées en vigueur
dans le monde dans le moment où la corde
est signée la discussion maintenant
suède et en finlande et surtout ce qu'il
va être le processus qui va aboutir
après à une signature de l'accord donc
pour beaucoup de monde surtout pour la
finlande plusieurs experts parlent d'un
processus relativement vite rapide parce
que la suède de la finlande ne devrait
pas passer le même processus
d'évaluation standard parce que les
capabilités les moyens des deux pays
sont bien connus à l'otan et il ya un
niveau très élevé de l'interopérabilité
ils ont participé à des opérations de la
mission otan en afghanistan
donc parfois on parle même d'un format
30 + 2 donc trompé de l'otan plus de la
finlande de la suède donc ils sont en
train d'en discuter un peu comme des des
pays membres qui peuvent eux pour avoir
un processus a un peu accéléré